good evening I'm Blake Hawkins and I am
a sophomore accounting major from Omaha
Nebraska and tonight I have the honor of
introducing our speaker our speaker is
Alan C Kelso he is a senior research
scholar at the Council of humanities and
a director of the initiative on politics
and statement ship in the James Madison
program at Princeton University dr.
Gelson is a MA and PhD from the
University of Pennsylvania in September
2005 he was nominated by President Bush
to the National Council on humanities
his articles and essays have appeared in
numerous publications including The Wall
Street Journal the Christian Science
Monitor the New York Times the Atlantic
and the Los Angeles Times he is the
author of several books including
Abraham Lincoln Abraham Lincoln Redeemer
President Lincoln and Douglas the
debates that defined America and a
fateful lightning a new history on the
of the history of the Civil War and
reconstruction without further ado dr.
Kelso
[Applause]
before I begin to talk about General Lee
this evening I want to say where to
thanks for the opportunity to be here at
Hillsdale College which is such a
remarkable remarkable institution I
wandered around a little bit this
morning I went over to see the chapel
and then I went over to the Student
Center and there I saw something I have
not seen in many many many years I saw
students diligently bent over tables
with cups of coffee reading Homer Pope
Latin and not only students but some
faculty people of my vintage so to speak
and I saw I saw male and female students
talking to each other with it and in an
innocence that brought to mind what it
must have been like before the knowledge
of the the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil but it was it was it was a
wonderful and and for me a touching
moment to see that kind of thing because
it has become sad to say so very rare
there's a description in Roger Scruton
the late Roger Scruton I say that with
great sorrow because he's now only just
in the past two weeks of course become
the late Roger Scruton
and he leaves he leaves quite a space
quite a space against the sky but in his
little book on hunting of all subjects
he had this to say students today their
students their studies in victimology
have all but deprived them of words and
their empty slogans and witless sneers
make me both ashamed for them and
anxious to invite them home for some
tutorials between bouts of pop music and
television they are handed jargon ridden
drivel by outdated Parisian guru
impenetrable texts of sociology the half
articulate leavings of the grievance
trade Scruton said what young people
need is nothing so much as wit illusion
and style they should be studying
advocacy and argument they should be
reading poetry criticism and the authors
who have said things clearly and well
thank you Larry on
Thank You Larry Arne thank you faculty
of Hillsdale Thank You trustees thank
you all who are friends and supporters
of Hillsdale for making what Scruton
described as the real goal for education
and students a real place here in ray
bad berries dystopian novel Fahrenheit
451 he described a world in which books
were burnt they were destroyed because
of course they might contain very
dangerous things like ideas one fireman
who had grown disenchanted with this ran
away and ran in pursuit of a rumor that
somewhere out in the swamps there were
small colonies of scholars and academics
and other Runaways who preserved the
books by memorizing them and this
runaway fireman found one of these
colonies in the swamps and he was
introduced to the people there and they
would step up and say hello i'm i'm dick
Hart I'm Descartes on first principles
or I'm I'm hello I'm Plato the symposium
they had memorized them to preserve them
and hand them down until a better time
would come when once again these works
could be printed and read and treasured
and I thought today there's a little bit
like being in that swamp much more
upscale
but the spirit the spirit was the same
and it has been a joy to be here and be
in the midst of it no one who met Robert
Edward Lee no matter what the
circumstances of the meeting ever seemed
to fail to be impressed by the man his
dignity his manners his composure all
seemed to create a peculiar sense of awe
in the minds of observers as a cadet at
West Point in the 1820s his classmate
and later fellow Confederate General
Joseph Johnston spoke of Lee having a
dignity which was as much a part of
himself as the elegance of his person
which evidenced a superiority that
everyone acknowledged in his heart in
the 1840s when he was posted as the
engineering officer at Fort Hamilton
guarding the approaches to the Narrows
of New York City one woman visitor
described Lee as a most elegant man
quite the ideal of a military hero who
received me with something more than
military courtesy bending his clear
handsome eye upon me 10 years later as
the superintendent of West Point from
1852 to 1855 he appeared to the young
John Schofield who would go on to carve
out a distinguished career of his own in
the army as the personification of
dignity justice and kindness and was
respected and admired as the ideal of a
commanding officer even in the midst of
battle at Fredericksburg in December of
1862 Lee awed Charles Francis Worley the
London Times special correspondent in
America for the serenity or if I may so
express it the unconscious dignity of
General Lee's courage when he is under
fire not even our friend
Ulysses Grant could escape the sense of
being upstaged by Lee at Appomattox he
was a man of much dignity with an
impassible face grant wrote in his
memoirs dressed in a full uniform which
was entirely new and wearing a sword of
considerable value while grant was
self-conscious of my rough traveling
suit the uniform of a private with the
straps of a Lieutenant General sewn on
I must have contrasted strangely grant
admitted with a man so handsomely
dressed six feet high and a faultless
form these impressions appear so
consistent and over so many years that
it has been easy to conclude that
dignity and manners and composure simply
were the man and that there was as
Douglass Sathya freamon insisted at the
end of his four volume biography of Lee
no mystery at all to robert e lee or as
burton Hendrick wrote in the Lee's of
Virginia that Lee's character was ruled
by a great simplicity or that in the
words of an even more worshipful
biographer Clifford Daugherty Lee could
rest totally in very simple things
however this picture of straightforward
well-nigh angelic serenity sits uneasily
beside moments when cracks and
inconsistencies in that fabled serenity
appeared for instance Lee worried
constantly and insistently about money
despite the fact that he had married
into one of the most prominent families
in the Washington DC orbit that of
George Washington Park Custis the step
grandson of George Washington and his
wife Mary Fitzhugh Custis who owned the
palatial estate that they called
Arlington perched Palatine
on the Potomac bluffs overlooking the
capital city in fact Robert Ely worried
about money even though according to the
will he filed before going off to fight
in the Mexican War he had actually
inherited quite a healthy sum from his
mother and Carter Lee and had invested
with enough success to have acquired a
portfolio worth thirty eight thousand
seven hundred and fifty dollars
translated into twenty twenty dollars
that's worth about 1.2 million it made
no difference at the same moment he
assured his West Point classmate Jack
Makai that it was as much as I could do
to make both ends meet this year and I
am anxiously looking for the dividend of
the Virginia bank to enable me to square
off all scores when Lee left Fort
Hamilton in 1847 for duty in the Mexican
War he complained to his brother that I
fear I have not enough to take me and my
servants of the army and purchase my
horses when he transferred out of the
Corps of Engineers in 1855 to become
lieutenant colonel of the 2nd Cavalry in
Texas he insisted on writing checks on
his alexandria bank from Texas for his
wife at Arlington to deposit for cash
and all the while shading her to be very
particular dear Mary when you deal in
money matters and to keep a memorandum
book and set everything down his advice
for his youngest son in 1856 was to
cultivate industry and frugality and be
prudent before he is liberal
and be just before he is generous other
kinds of cracks opened under pressure
trained as an engineer and the director
of a series of demanding coastal
engineering projects from controlling
the silting up of the st. Louis
waterfront
to the construction of Fort Carroll in
Baltimore Harbor Lee was at his happiest
with a draftsman notebook in hand and
impatient at every other sort of
paperwork
I abhor the sight of pen and paper he
admitted and to put one to the other
requires as great a moral effort as for
a cat to walk on live coals this did not
prevent him from writing over four
thousand letters in his lifetime but
that was personal correspondence
official papers were his bane he also
grew impatient when matters spilled out
of the kind of perfection that t-squares
and equations can impose after the close
of the Maryland campaign in 1862 he
unleashed on his two chief subordinates
James Longstreet and Stonewall Jackson a
long lecture by letter on the
depredations committed by this army its
daily diminution and the loss of arms
thrown aside as too burdensome by
stragglers it would be impossible to
imagine Ulysses Grant writing a letter
like this to William Tecumseh Sherman or
James B McPherson but for Lee no
shortcoming in either of these
commanders missed his perfect eye roll
calls are neglected and officers of
companies and regiments are ignorant of
the true condition of their commands and
are unable to account properly for
absent ease he now wanted a brigade
guard to bring up the rear of each
brigade to keep up the ranks drive up
all stragglers irrespective of commands
and all leaving the ranks
we must he demanded infuse a different
spirit among our officers which was more
or less what he found a begging in the
Confederacy as a whole our people are so
little liable to control that it is
difficult to get them to follow any
course not in accordance with their
inclination he had
to Eustace Schubert the Prussian
military observer and when shy Bert
expressed frankly my admiration for the
lion-like bravery of his men Lee
disagreed give me also Prussian
discipline and Prussian forms and you
would see quite different results that
perfectionism was linked to a more
easily agitated temper than easily met
they met the I Walter Taylor who has
Lee's adjutant during the Civil War had
to short and docket the incoming mail
discovered that Lee had lost nothing of
his engineers distaste for office work
especially if it was heavy with matters
of detail coming from the personal
commands of our army which demanded the
personal consideration and decision of
the commander of the army if Taylor
brought him some case of a vexatious
character Lee's irritation would flare
up gradually beginning with a little
nervous twist or jerk of the neck and
head and eventually erupting into a
full-fledged argument he is so
unreasonable and provoking Taylor raged
to his fiance in a letter I never worked
so hard to please anyone and with so
little effect as General Lee Charles
Marshall who handled Lee's outgoing
correspondence had an only slightly
easier task because Lee either dictated
first drafts or allowed Marshall to draw
up documents himself but then Lee
weighed every sentence I wrote
frequently making minut verbal
alterations and questioned me closely as
to the evidence on which I based all
statements which he did not know to be
correct he did not allow any friend of
soldiers condemned by court-martial to
reach his tent for personal appeal
remembered Charles Venable another
member of his civil worst
and when such disappointed men elbowed
their way into his presence Lee would
bark not only at the petitioner but at
Venable for not preventing the annoyance
why did you permit that man to come to
my tent and make me show my temper one
of Stonewall Jackson's staff officers
asked an innocent question while making
a report to Lee and Lee's response at
this impertinence was so frosty that the
staffer remarked I never felt so small
in my life even Lee's son George
Washington Custis Lee who was attached
to Confederate President Jefferson
Davis's personal staff had to endure his
father's flare-ups reading letters from
his father
complaining that he was so tired of the
pettiness of the Confederate Congress
that he wished they would pass a law
relieving me from all duty and
legislating someone in my place better
able to do it I fear you will think I am
in a bad humor and I fear I am but the
deepest mark of the depths of Lee's
temper occurred in the spring of 1859
when his father-in-law died in 1857 Lee
was named executor of the Custis estate
which to his surprise required him to
superintend the Emancipation within five
years of all the Custis slaves at
Arlington and two other Custis owned
properties Lee could not hurry to
execute this emancipation because the
will also mandated that for $10,000
legacies be paid to each of Lee's
daughters since the properties had been
run haphazardly for years by old Custis
Lee would need to turn them into engines
of efficiency to pay the required
legacies and that he did with an
engineer's sense of precision but the
Custis slaves
did not share his interest in making
Arlington and the other places
profitable they believed that the Custis
will had in fact emancipated them at
once and in 1858 three of them two men
and a woman acted on that belief and
fled to Westminster Maryland where they
were eventually apprehended and returned
to Arlington his fabled self-control
teetering unsteadily Lee demanded of the
three why they ran away because they
replied frankly we considered ourselves
free that to Robert Lee was not merely a
legal misapprehension it was a threat to
his own integrity as the Custis wills
executor and the future of his
daughter's he then told us he would
teach us a lesson we would never forget
and ordered the three stripped to the
waist and directed the arlington
overseer john McQuinn to give the men
fifty lashes each and 22 the woman
McQuinn bald and had sufficient humanity
to decline so Lee turned to Richard
Williams the Arlington constable who had
brought the fugitives back and had him
perform the whipping while Lee demanded
he lay it on well by one account Lee
took the whip in his own hands and
flayed them himself afterwards he was so
appalled at his own rage that he could
not admit the full extent of what he had
done even to his son Custis who read
about the incident in the newspapers the
New York Tribune has attacked me for my
treatment of your grandfather's slaves
he conceded to Custis but I shall not
reply your grandfather he added has left
me and unpleasant legacy
robert e lee's anxieties his impatience
and his dark temper have since the
publication of thomas Connolly's
melodramatic recasting of lee's
historical reputation in the marble man
robert e lee and his image in american
society in 1977 been seized upon as a
triumphant contradiction of the
legendary lee who so impressed his
contemporaries civilian and military to
alan Nolan in 1991 Lee was just a
typical southern partisan with all the
southern aristocrats feeling for the
inferiority of northern people to
Michael Fellman in 2000 Lee was really
an exemplar of the dark side of the
white supremacist road to Roy Blount
probably the most unlikely of all Lee
biographers in 2003 Lee was mentally and
pathologically disturbed but casting Lee
in contradiction as either st. Horace
sinner as either simple or pathological
is in the end less profitable then
seeing his anxieties as a counterpoint
to his dignity his impatience and his
temper as a match to his composure
to begin to understand the mystery of
robert e lee is to begin with three
large scale factors lodged deep in the
man's personality one of these was the
desire for perfection then the desire
for independence and then the desire for
security
all three were rooted in the early
trauma inflicted by one of the more
remarkably dysfunctional families of the
early republic up through the revolution
the lee's of virginia had been one of
the first of american families
presiding over large properties on the
Northern Neck of Virginia and in the
case of the for Lee brothers who
straddled the Revolutionary years
Richard Henry Lee Francis Lightfoot Lee
author and William Lee they were that
band of brothers according to John Adams
intrepid and unchangeable who stood in
the gap in defense of their country from
the first glimmering of the revolution
through all its rising light to its
perfect day Richard Henry Lee and
Francis Lightfoot Lee both served in the
Continental Congress at the outbreak of
the Revolution and they are the only
brothers who appear as signers of the
Declaration of Independence Arthur Lee
would turn into an outstanding diplomat
in Spain and France and William Lee
would represent American interests in
the German states and Austria but
something in the succeeding generation
of Lee's snapped and nowhere was the
snap louder than in the gentlemen whose
pictures on the screen behind me that of
Henry Lee the third Roberts father Henry
Lee was a graduate of Princeton my
employer in the same class of 1771 as
James Madison Henry Lee served George
Washington's so effectively as a cavalry
leader that he won the nickname Light
Horse Harry and in the glow of the
revolution
Lighthorse Harry captured not only the
hand of his cousin Matilda and her
family's estate Stratford Hall but he
also captured the governorship of
Virginia nothing seemed beyond his grasp
after that however Lighthorse Harry
disintegrated his ardent federalism
antagonized Virginia's Jeffersonians his
harebrained investment schemes
bankrupted him after Matilda's death he
attempted to recoup his fortune by
marrying a Virginia Carter and Hill
Carter but he burned through her cash
too or at least the limited amount of
cash her father had prudently put at the
newlyweds disposal
Henry Lee were alive today he'd invest
in ski resorts in Bangladesh after he
spent a stint in debtors prison the
sadder but wiser and Carter Lee demanded
that her family which now numbered three
sons including Robert and two daughters
moved to more manageable quarters in
Alexandria but Lighthorse Harry could
not shake his penchant for disaster
after being beaten within an inch of his
life in an anti federalists riot in
Baltimore in 1812 Light Horse Harry
decamped the following year for the
safety of the West Indies Robert never
saw his father again he was six years
old
Light Horse Harry only returned to
America fatally ill in 1818 barely
making landfall in Georgia before dying
and leaving Robert to grow up in literal
as well as figurative terms fatherless
there is wrote the literary critic Leon
it'll no hurt among all the human hurts
deeper and less understandable than the
loss of a parent when one is not yet an
adolescent and robert e lee offers us a
textbook case and the truth of that
saying until eh-eh achieved fame in his
own right in 1862 people invariably
referred to robert as the son of the
famed Light Horse Harry but he never did
except in his application letter to West
Point he did not visit his father's
grave until the winter of 1861 to 62
even though his first posting out of
West Point to Cockspur Island was only a
few miles away he was instead his
mother's son becoming the de facto head
of household in Alexandria it was Robert
who carried the keys attended to the
marketing managed all the outdoor
business and took care of his mother's
horses when his mother was ill it was
Robert who ordered up the family's
shabby Brougham and then would be seen
carrying her in his arms to the carriage
and arranging her cushions with the
gentleness of an experienced nurse one
of the flock of Lee cousins in
Alexandria remembered that Robert became
legendary for his devotion to his mother
and the great help he was to her in all
her business and household matters years
later he would simply describe himself
as my mother's outdoor agent and
confidential messenger he would in other
words fulfill the role his father had
abandoned he would sacrifice himself in
order to perfect the imperfections
Lighthorse Harry had visited on the
Lee's this pursuit of redemptive
perfection
lies behind much of the marble model
that met so many people's eyes and it
was Lee's determination to be not Light
Horse Harry when everyone expected him
to be a reprise of his narrative well
father which fired his impatience and
eventually his ferocious outbursts of
temper at his own and others
imperfections that did not mean that
Robert would enjoy the shackles and
demands of perfection and it came as a
shock to and Carter Lee when in 1824
Robert announced his desire to leave her
home in Alexandria and attend West Point
how can I live without Robert she wailed
he is both son and daughter to me she
would have been more disturbed if she
could have sensed how much Robert
for all of his uncomplaining
self-sacrifice longed to be free and
unencumbered of his mother as much as
his father
I thought he wrote and intended always
to be one and alone in the world I am
fond of independence Lee wrote and that
as he explained in 1851 was linked to
his perfectionist impulse it is that
feeling that prompts me to come up
strictly to the requirements of law and
regulations
I wish neither to seek or receive
indulgence from anyone I wish to feel
under obligation to no one
the problem with longing for
independence is that it does not
guarantee security and security which
precisely the damaging subtraction
Lighthorse Harry made in Roberts life so
as much as Robert Lee longed to be his
own man he was also aware that the
independent man could very well be the
impoverished lonely neglected man
and he did not want that either one of
the major attractions of a career in the
US Army was its guarantee of lifetime
employment security for the tiny cadre
of officers who commanded the pre-civil
war army
there was no retirement system once in
many stayed in and at paid rank until
their last breath the army was not
generous and promotion was agonizingly
slow but it was one of the few
professions in the pre Civil War
Republic which was secure all my schemes
of happiness he wrote depend on retiring
to some quiet corner among the hills of
Virginia where I can indulge my natural
propensities without interruption but
when his older brother Carter tried to
persuade him to leave the army and do
just that with the 17,000 acres in hardy
Patrick and Shenandoah counties that
they had inherited from their father
Robert hesitated perhaps the charms of
your establishment may win me from Uncle
Sam he replied to Carter in 1832 but in
the end he decided not the army was his
place for better for worse as we say in
matrimony and he would have to
relinquish such prospects as Western
Virginia offered to bachelors like
yourself matrimony was yet another path
to security for in 1831 Lee married Mary
Anna randolph Custis the sole surviving
child of the Arlington Custis 'as and
thereby won himself a permanent home at
Arlington for the next 30 years the
difficulty was that the security
represented by the Custis marriage and
Arlington did not sit very easily beside
Lee's yearning for independence his
Custis in-laws made no secret of their
desire to withdraw
Robert from his present professions and
yield to him the management of affairs
but Lee had no desire to abandon the
army merely to become the glorified
overseer of the Custis 'as despite his
very real affection for his
mother-in-law Lee found his
father-in-law an amiable but annoying
dunce the major the elderly Custis --is
honorary militia title the major is busy
farming Lee wrote to Carter busy was
sardonic his cornfield is not yet
enclosed or plowed but he is rushing on
all he knows the old man had tried his
hand at writing a Sir Walter Scottish
play about 13th century Scotland which
he called montgomery or the orphan of a
wreck it ran for four nights and so as
lead chuckled montgomery failed worse
still one of Custis 'as six amateurish
history paintings the Battle of Trenton
has been exhibited in the capital and
met with more or less the same response
it attracted some severe animate
versions from the critics which he says
were leveled at his politics Lee knew
better seven months into the Civil War
when Arlington had been lost to Union
occupation Lee shrugged off the estate's
loss and turned his attention to the
possibility of acquiring another
property nothing less than his one-time
boyhood home stratford hall stratford he
wrote is endeared to me by many
recollections and it has always been a
great desire of my life to be able to
purchase it he might have found security
in attaching himself to the
but he earned for the independence of
being ally and nothing symbolized that
more than Stratford and perhaps it was
knowing no coincidence that two months
later robert e lee finally paid his
father's grave on Cumberland Island a
long delayed visit
robert e lee was not a profound thinker
his compulsive letter-writing betrays
little evidence of reading beyond the
demands of his profession but he was a
clear thinker and much of that thinking
oscillated among the polls he had set up
for himself of perfection independence
and security and that was particularly
true in his role as the Confederacy's
most successful and influential soldier
Lee was incessant in his demands on the
Confederacy's civilian leadership for
supplies conscripts and recruits and for
the perfection on the part of his
officers time and again Lee complained
beaten federal armies will get away
because I cannot have my orders carried
out when one hapless Brigadier had to
report the federal escape after
Chancellorsville Lee's fury was volcanic
general Pender that is what you young
men always do you allow those people to
get away but beyond the demand for
perfection Lee also saw more clearly
than any other Confederate leader that
the south could not survive a long
drawn-out bout with the north
independence and security both dictated
that southern armies must cross Maryland
into Pennsylvania and they're convinced
northerners either by battle or by
simple occupation to agree to peace and
southern independence he would attempt
this twice in 1862 and 1863 and he was
ready for a third attempt in 1864 when
grants Overland campaign struck that
option away this strategy which some
have characterized as audacity was for
Lee merely logic Lee's modern critics
have railed against what they do
is Lee's obsession with Virginia at the
expense of the rest of the Confederacy
but Lee understood that the Confederacy
could lose Tennessee Mississippi Alabama
even Georgia and still win
losing Virginia meant losing nearly 20%
of the Confederacy's white population
17% of its banking capital 1/3 of its
industrial goods and 40% of its wheat
Richmond alone held the Confederacy's
depots and Arsenal's and through
Richmond Lee's army had its chief means
of access to sources of supply for the
south he dreaded nothing more that being
forced into a siege of Richmond he
frequently spoke recalled Charles
Marshall to the effect that if the siege
of Richmond were once undertaken by an
army too strong to be beaten off the
fault of the place would be inevitable
and with it would go Virginia and the
Confederacy which in 1865 is exactly
what happened Lee had foreseen it all
and understood it as a failure to meet
the standard of perfect commitment it is
so difficult he admitted to his wife to
get our people on accustomed to the
necessities of war to comprehend the
measures required for the occasion
instead they failed the standard of
perfect commitment that independence and
security required Lee told William
Mahone at Appomattox that he had advised
the Confederate authorities at the start
that the contest on which we had entered
could not be overestimated and our
chance to win was to be found by
throwing the whole military or fighting
power of the Confederacy into the
struggle and this he said manifestly had
not been done
yet this was not the final chapter for
robert e lee in the summer of 1865 he
was made the unlikely offer of the
presidency of Washington College in
faraway Lexington Virginia almost as
unlikely he accepted and in the final
five years of his life he managed to
achieve the resolution of the impulses
to perfection independence and security
that he had spent a lifetime seeking the
trustees of the college were
congratulated on acquiring a figurehead
but Lee made them the figureheads and he
turned the nearly bankrupt College into
a southern educational powerhouse
outstripping even the University of
Virginia when he assumed the presidency
in 1865 Washington College had only 17
students on the rolls after one year Lee
had built that to 146 by 1868
enrollments stood at 411
he also took in hand the reconstruction
of the curriculum sidelining the
traditional studies of Greek and Latin
one thing for which I have not yet
forgiven him in favor of recreating
Washington College as a commercial
school to give instruction in
bookkeeping and the forms and of details
of business no wonder he would remark
looking back that the great mistake of
my life was taking a military education
a small remote College would become
instead the place where he would find
independence to run matters as he saw
fit security for himself and his family
and perfection in what he could demand
of his students
perhaps in retrospect we can say that
Robert Lee should have shrugged off the
shadow of Light Horse Harry perhaps he
should have left the army and built a
real estate empire in western Virginia
perhaps he should have become the
handsome but aloof family overseer of
Arlington and let the Civil War wash
past him but he did not and the forces
that made him what he was in the past
governed the extraordinary skill with
which he managed Confederate military
affairs those forces did not however
make him a happy man that only came at
the end in Lexington but it was a
perfect end thank you very much
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Gaz Kells oh we now have
time for Q&A please make your way to the
microphone if you have a question thank
you doctor
I'd like you to comment on a man who's
often quoted as saying do your duty and
all things you can never do more you
should never do less and then he
violated his oath to the Constitution
United States when I look at the figure
of robert e lee I look at it and this
will surprise nobody as a Yankee from
Yankee land so I am an unlikely Lee
biographer and to say the least and that
never comes more to a point than on the
question that I'm probably most
frequently asked this way did robert e
lee commit treason and i think there's
only one answer to that and it's
inescapable the answer is yes yes he
committed treason he had served in the
United States Army for 30-some years he
had sworn the oath he had fought under
the stars and stripes in Mexico and he
consciously turned against all of that
and I don't have another way of speaking
of Lee except to use that word it is the
Constitution's definition Constitution
defines treason as making war against
the United States and giving aid and
comfort to its enemies I don't have a
different I don't have some mystical way
of being able to get around that and
seeing Robert Ely is not capturing
precisely that reprehensible behavior I
understand that there were many
contingencies and there were many
qualifications which went into his
decision in 1861 yet at the same time I
have in past time sworn an oath
to preserve protect and defend the
Constitution my father swore that oath
my son has sworn that oath and whether
it's robert e lee or not when you raise
your hand against that flag and that
constitution you are my enemy and i will
regard you as such and i do not hesitate
to say that if by some odd transposition
of time i should find myself with robert
e lee and my gunsights i would not
hesitate to pull the trigger I don't say
that with pride or pleasure but I say it
as a reality recognizing the seriousness
of what he did he was at the close of
the war indicted for treason it never
came to trial there were a number of
legal complications which got in the way
of anything like that but if we are to
look at robert e lee and see him as we
should see him as a citizen who has
obligations under the Constitution of
the United States then there really is
no other word that we can use and no way
to escape from that word it robert e lee
committed treason I don't have a better
way of putting it I hope that answers
the question
[Applause]
we have time for one more question there
are historians in the medical military
history that speak to robert e lee's
state of health especially his problems
with congestive heart failure and how
they may have affected his judgment and
his ability to command starting at
Gettysburg could you comment on that
robert e lee began suffering symptoms of
angina in the 1850s when he was then
lieutenant colonel of the second cavalry
in texas it was referred to then as
rheumatism but knowing the subsequent
developments of his medical history it
seems pretty plain that these are the
first symptoms that we begin to see and
it shows up more dramatically in the
spring of 1863 when he has a heart
attack
oh it just he has all the classic
symptoms he's he's bedridden for almost
a month and he tries to in letters to
his wife he truck because he he is he
stays with the army he doesn't he
doesn't go back to Richmond and let
family take care of him he stays with
his army but the letters that he writes
he's always trying to downplay the
seriousness of what has happened well
I've got a very bad cold the doctors
have been thumping me like an old steam
boiler but it was a heart attack he had
a second one in the fall of 1863 less
severe but severe enough that he could
not ride he had to get around in a wagon
or an ambulance and and the terms wagon
and ambulance in the Civil War almost
interchangeable he has a case of
dysentery in the spring of 1864 at the
the apex of the Overland campaign and
one reason why grant is able to move as
fast as grant does and move around Lee
is that Lee is just not up to par in
terms of health so there are repeated
health problems that Lee deals with and
and which plague him and affect his
performance bear in mind that
he is the oldest field commander in the
Civil War he is 56 years old at the time
of the Battle of Gettysburg Ulysses
Grant by contrast is 41 William Tecumseh
Sherman 43 now you go down the list of
other major figures in the Civil War
same thing George McClellan was 39 Lee
is the oldest and some respects given
the rigors of 19th century campaigning
which is literally living in the rough
it takes its toll on him physically and
as a toll which he probably should have
recognized and it leads him in August of
1863 partly because of the defeat of
Gettysburg but also partly because of
health his health considerations to
offer his resignation to Jefferson Davis
Davis refuses where Davis says in reply
where would I find someone more capable
of command than yourself and that was
true because even robert e lee plagued
with angina was was was infinitely more
resourceful than any other secondary
commanders who could have been put into
his place when he complained about
officers and generals not taking his
orders seriously not carrying them out
perfectly he was not exaggerating who
would who would have have taken Lee's
place there was no deep bench in the
Confederacy so Lee soldiers on and he
goes all the way to Appomattox and what
I think is poignant is that he goes to
Appomattox saying to William Nelson
Pendleton I always knew that it would
turn out this way he saw it from the
beginning please join me in thinking dr.
Gelles oh thank you very much
you